[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend zum
Nachrichtenüberblick an diesem Montag
die vom Sport hat Norbert Lehmann
wir haben unter anderem diese Themen für
Sie
F16 Kampfjets für die Ukraine die Zusage
der Dänen und Niederländer befeuert die
Debatte über die Lieferung von deutschen
taurus-marschflugkörpern
Wohnungsbau auf Talfahrt wegen hoher
Zinsen und steigender Baukosten rutscht
die Baubranche immer tiefer in die Krise
eh klar im spanischen wm-taumel
fußballchef robiales küsst die Spielerin
ermasso mit Nachdruck auf den Mund sie
sagt es habe ihr nicht gefallen
[Musik]
die F16 Kampfjets aus den Niederlanden
und Dänemark werden erst in einigen
Monaten zum Einsatz kommen aber für die
Ukraine ist allein die Zusage ein enorm
wichtiges Signal nicht nur militärisch
dänemark hat angekündigt 19 Maschinen
abzugeben sechs davon zum Jahreswechsel
die Niederlande verfügen über 42 F16
Jets wie viele davon geliefert werden
können ist noch offen Deutschland hat
keine Kampfflugzeuge diesen Typs dafür
aber Taurus Marschflugkörper die
ebenfalls von der Ukraine angefragt
wurden Florian neuhahn berichtet
am Mittag vor dem dänischen Parlament
tausende jubeln als der
parlamentsprecher einen wie er sagt
großen Helden unserer Zeit begrüßt und
der so vorgestellte bedankt sich
auch mit einer Ansage
heute sind wir zuversichtlich dass
Russland diesen Krieg verlieren wird
ein Grund für diese Zuversicht dass am
Wochenende erstmals zwei NATO-Staaten
die Lieferung von westlichen F16
Kampfjets zugesagt haben 19 Jets will
Dänemark liefern weitere die Niederlande
die ersten Jets dürften erst zum
Jahresende in der Ukraine eintreffen und
so ist die Zusage heute zunächst eine
Botschaft
es ist ein Zeichen das hoffentlich in
Moskau verstanden wird dass sich die
NATO Alliierten hier auf lange Sicht
verpflichtet haben zur Lieferung von
Kampf des gehören schließlich
langfristige Wartung langfristiges
Training
theoretisch könnten die Kampfjets bis
weit in russisches Gebiet hinein
angreifen praktisch vertrauen die beiden
NATO-Staaten einem Versprechen der
Ukraine dies nicht zu tun in Berlin
befeuert die Nachricht daher eine seit
Wochen laufende Debatte um Taurus
Marschflugkörper ebenfalls mit hoher
Reichweite ist ein verlässlicher Partner
und wenn die Niederländer und denen die
F16 schicken sollte der Bundeskanzler
und das Bundeskanzleramt jetzt ein Herz
über den Zaun werfen und die Freigabe
für den Taurus geben von der
Bundesregierung heute nur so viel ist
gebe keine neuen Stand Berlin diskutiert
noch
Millionen Ukrainer Leben in den Gebieten
die von der russischen Armee besetzt
sind viele von ihnen wollen in den
freien Teil der Ukraine doch wegen der
Kämpfe und wegen Minenfeldern ist das so
gut wie unmöglich nur an einer Stelle
tut sich derzeit diese Möglichkeit auf
und zwar in krasnopilia unsere
reporterin Anne Brühl hat dort Frauen
getroffen die einen langen Weg in Kauf
genommen haben sogar über russisches
Staatsgebiet um wieder in Ukrainisch
kontrollierte Regionen zu gelangen
Luftalarm in krasnopilla fast täglich
wird der Ort von russische Militär
beschossen und doch ist der so etwas wie
ein hoffnungsort denn unweit von hier
ist die Grenze
durchlässigten Gebieten kommen die die
in der Ukraine weiterleben wollen soweit
ich weiß werden sie da oft beschossen
aus der Ukraine in die Ukraine unter
Lebensgefahr bis zur russischen Grenze
sind es nur ein paar Kilometer dort
liegt der einzige Übergang an dem es
möglich ist von Russland aus in die
Ukraine zu gelangen Filmen dürfen wir
das nicht aus Sicherheitsgründen
Freiwillige wie Vitali koordinieren die
Hilfe wen die Russen rüber lassen unklar
die Gruppe auf die wir kurz hinter der
Grenze warten ist unterwegs
die Menschen werden müde sein
psychologisch erschöpft
plötzlich sind sie da vor allem Frauen
Kinder viele hier haben seit
Kriegsbeginn unter russischer Besatzung
gelebt
eineinhalb Jahre habe ich meinen Mann
nicht gesehen und endlich kehren wir
zurück jetzt hoffen sie auf einen
Neuanfang ultra kommt aus melittopol
ihren Sohn haben die Russen nicht
rausgelassen
man zwingt die Leute dazu Pässe
anzunehmen denn man kann weder in die
Schule gehen noch sich im Krankenhaus
behandeln lassen an der Rezeption steht
geschrieben dass man zur Sprechstunde
nur dann darf wenn man einen russischen
Pass hat
für die meisten nur Zwischenstation sie
wollen weiter erstmal in Sicherheit
es sei das größte Militärmanöver aller
Zeiten so beschreibt das südkoreanische
Militär die diesjährigen Übungen mit den
USA zehntausende Soldaten bei der Länder
nehmen an dem manöverteil um die
gemeinsame Reaktion auf die Bedrohung
durch Nordkorea zu verbessern kurz vor
Beginn feuerte Nordkorea vom Japanischen
Meer aus mehrere strategische
Marschflugkörper ab nach Regime
nach Deutschland nach Ansicht des
ifo-Instituts braut sich beim
Wohnungsbau ein Sturm zusammen es werden
zwar dringend neue Wohnungen gebraucht
doch die höheren Zinsen und die
drastisch gestiegenen Baukosten wirkten
den Neubau zunehmend ab
bauministerin Gallwitz ist das bewusst
sie wehrt sich gegen strengere Vorgaben
bei der Dämmung die bauen noch teurer
machen würden Klaus Brodbeck
dämmen je mehr desto teurer gasstandard
eher 40 übertrieben findet die
bauministerin gerade in der aktuellen
Lage ich rate davon ab dass wir in der
jetzigen Situation wo die Bauwirtschaft
in einer großen Krise ist und wo die
Neubauzahlen einbrechen das tun denn wir
brauchen dringend Wachstumsimpulse und
nicht mehr Standards das ist die Lage im
Wohnungsbau 40% der Unternehmen klagen
über Auftragsmangel fast 19% berichten
von Stornierungen Ergebnisse einer heute
veröffentlichen Studie des
ivo-institutes
im Wohnungsbau braut sich gerade der
perfekte Sturm sozusagen zusammen 40
Prozent der Wohnungsbauunternehmen sagen
dass sie keine neuen Aufträge bekommen
auf der anderen Seite haben auch knapp
jedes fünftes Unternehmen gesagt dass
sie Aufträge storniert bekommen das ist
also wie eine Art zangbewegung die die
Unternehmen gehörig unter Druck setzt
der verschärfte Energiestandard eher 40
steht zwar im Koalitionsvertrag
bauministerin SPD und Finanzminister FDP
wollen nun aber bis September ein
Konzept vorlegen dass die Wirtschaft
ankurbeln und bauen erleichtern soll ich
halte es auch Ausbau fachlicher Sicht
für einen zu engen Ansatz alleine die
Frage des dämms in den Blick zu nehmen
wenn man über ökologisches Bauen spricht
wir haben eine Holzbau Initiative wir
wollen mehr mit Recyclingmaterial bauen
der auf grüner Seite zuständige
Wirtschaftsminister aber wurde bislang
noch nicht einbezogen gut möglich dass
der Ampel hier neuer Streit droht
die Linke steckt tief in der Krise in
Umfragen bundesweit meist unter fünf
Prozent auch im Osten geschrumpft und
verheerend auch das öffentliche Bild es
herrscht Streit die Fraktionsspitzen Ali
und Bartsch wollen nicht mehr antreten
Sarah Wagenknecht liebäugel damit eine
neue Partei zu gründen
Parteichefin Wissler gab sich heute
trotzdem zuversichtlich Daniel
die Frage ob sie selbst zur Wahl stehen
werde als Fraktionsvorsitzende hat
Janine Wissler einmal bereits
unbeantwortet gelassen bei dieser
Pressekonferenz vor dieser Nachfrage
ziehen sie denn zumindest in Betracht
selbst zu kandidieren
also wir werden die nächsten Tage
Gespräche führen ich möchte da jetzt
nicht spekulieren oder irgendwie vor
Überlegungen
öffentlich an
angehen sondern wir werden das in den
nächsten Tagen miteinander besprechen
seit Sarah Wagenknecht erwägt eine
eigene Partei zu gründen kämpft die
Linke gegen Zerfallserscheinungen das
Wagenknecht Lager sieht die Parteispitze
und damit auch eine mögliche Kandidatur
wisslers für den Fraktionsvorsitz
kritisch so auch deren jüngste
Entscheidung mit Carola Rakete eine
klimaaktivistin für die Europawahl zu
nominieren
definitiv keine integrative Kraft sie
hat die Partei gestalten auch mit ihrem
Positionen wenn der Vorstand der Partei
nicht zur Vernunft kommt und bei dieser
neuen veränderten Grünen Partei grüner
als die Grünen bleiben will dann wird er
nicht nur Leute aus dem aus dem
Bundestag verlieren sondern dann würde
höchstwahrscheinlich auf dem großen Teil
der Mitglieder verlieren nur wenigen der
39 Abgeordneten wird zugetraut überhaupt
eine Mehrheit in der zerstrittenen
Fraktion zu bekommen und diese
Hoffnungsträger wiederum Schein eher auf
einen Generationswechsel zu setzen
sowohl Gregor Gysi als auch Dietmar Bart
als auch ich werden ja in jedem Falle
weiterhin aktiv für die Partei auftreten
und an den entsprechenden Stellen auch
mitarbeiten und es ist auch unsere
Aufgabe jüngere zu unterstützen und
bekannter zu machen heute in zwei Wochen
soll die Wahl zum Fraktionsvorsitz
stattfinden
in Eisenach in Thüringen breitet sich
seit langem die rechtsextreme Szene aus
das sagt das Institut für Demokratie und
Zivilgesellschaft auch die
kampfsportgruppe Knockout 51 wurde in
Eisenach gegründet vier mutmaßliche
Mitglieder stehen seit heute vor Gericht
sie sollen nicht nur politische Gegner
und Polizisten schwer attackiert sondern
auch gezielte Tötungen geplant haben
Christoph Schneider
unter großen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
beginnt am Vormittag vor dem
Staatsschutz senat des
Oberlandesgerichts Jena der Prozess
gegen vier mutmaßliche Rechtsextremisten
aus dem Raum Eisenach die Vorwürfe der
Bundesanwaltschaft sind gravierend
den vier Angeklagten wird unter anderem
die Mitgliedschaft in einer kriminellen
Vereinigung der rechtsextremen
kampfsportgruppe Nord 51 zu Last gelegt
bei nocket 51 ging es nicht um die rein
sportliche Betätigung viel mehr sahen
sich die Angeklagten als politische
Soldaten der rechtsextremen Szene an bei
groß angelegten deutschlandweiten
Razzien in der rechten Szene Anfang
April 2022 flog das angeklagte Quartet
um den redelsführer Leon R auf unter dem
dickmantel des kampfsporttrainings habe
die Gruppe junge nationalistisch
gesinnte Männer angeworben um
gewalttätige Aktionen durchzuführen so
die Ankläger und er sei Bindeglied
zwischen verschiedenen
rechtsextremistischen Szenen wie auch
der rechtsrockszene gewesen
für die Bundesanwaltschaft ist klar es
soll bei der Gruppe darum gegangen sein
ganze Stadtviertel unter die eigene
Vormachtstellung zu bringen mit
gezielten Anschlägen und Überfällen auf
politische Gegner das Gericht will sich
Zeit lassen die Entwicklungen als nach
aufzuklären und insbesondere der Frage
nachzugehen inwieweit hier eine
Radikalisierung unter dem Deckmantel des
Kampfsports stattgefunden hat
für den Prozess sind bislang gut 40
Verhandlungstage bis Mitte kommenden
Jahres angesetzt
heftige Vorwürfe an Saudi-Arabien kommen
von der Menschenrechtsorganisation human
right Swatch danach hätten Beamte an der
saudischemenitischen Grenze
äthiopische Migranten systematisch
erschossen auch Kinder und teils aus
nächster Nähe geschehen sei das zwischen
März 2022 und Juni dieses Jahres das
hätten Interviews Fotos und
Satellitenbilder ergeben das Auswärtige
Amt äußerte sich besorgt zu den
Berichten
der 21 August 2013 hat sich vielen
Syrern ins Gedächtnis gebrannt vor zehn
Jahren traf das Land mitten im
Bürgerkrieg einer der tödlichsten
chemiewaffenangriffe in Gotha nahe der
Damas Hauptstadt Damaskus schlugen
damals mehrere Raketen ein bestückt mit
dem Nervengas Sarin mehr als 1.000
Menschen verloren ihr Leben erstickten
teils im Schlaf die die überlebt haben
leiden noch immer anders heißt
immer wenn Abu Malik seine Tochter
anschaut dann kommen die Erinnerungen
hoch
die Ärzte sagten sie hat unter
Sauerstoffmangel gelitten sie fragten wo
habt ihr gelebt ich sagte dort wo sie
mit sarinas bombardiert haben
am 21 August 2013 wird guter zum Ziel
eines der ringasangriffs das ist ein
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit zehn
Jahre danach ist sich die
Weltgemeinschaft einig das hinter der
Attacke höchstwahrscheinlich das Regime
von Assad
dr Ayman hatte damals Dienst die Bilder
erträgt er kaum
bis heute zehn Jahre später heilen
unsere Wunden nicht denn es gibt keine
Gerechtigkeit
der Arzt lebt heute im Nordwesten
Syriens im Rebellengebiet sowie die
meisten Überlebenden von guter die hier
Schutz vor Ersatz suchten eigentlich
sollten Sie von den internationalen
Hilfslieferungen profitieren doch die
kommen hier nicht an nun gibt es gar ein
neues Abkommen das besagt dass alle
Hilfe vom Regime kontrolliert wird
wenn das syrische Regime die humanitäre
Hilfe regelt dann wird es zu einer
massiven Katastrophe kommen
ein Vorgeschmack darauf liefern diese
Bilder unterwegs in Ersatz Damaskus wir
drehen mit versteckter Kamera und finden
überall internationale Hilfslieferung im
Angebot Sonnenblumenöl vom
Welternährungsprogramm der Vereinten
Nationen mit der Inschrift nicht für den
Verkauf bestimmt und hunderte Päckchen
Notnahrung für Mangel ernährte Kinder
hier im Angebot für umgerechnet 15 bis
30 Cent Nahrung die in den Camps im
Nordwesten so bitter nötig wäre seit 41
Tagen kommt nichts mehr
ich gebe ihnen Nahrung das ist doch
unmenschlich
blanker Hohn sei das das ausgerechnet
der Mann der Krieg gegen sie führt nun
die Kontrolle habe über ihre Hilfsgüter
nach Guatemala der Frühling ist da mit
solchen Plakaten feiern die Menschen
dort den überraschenden Sieg des
Sozialdemokraten Bernardo arriva lo bei
der Stichwahl um das Präsidentenamt der
64-Jährige hat der Korruption im Land
den Kampf angesagt
guatemala ist mit 17 Millionen
Einwohnern das bevölkerungsreichste Land
Mittelamerikas Armut und Gewalt sorgen
dafür dass jährlich tausende
Guatemalteken versuchen über Mexiko in
die USA auszuwandern mehr von MRT wissen
sie feiern nichts weniger als ein Wunder
so sehen es die Anhänger von Bernardo
arabello der diese Wahl mit 58% der
Stimmen gewann gegen eine Politiker
Elite die seit Jahrzehnten die Macht in
Guatemala besaß
[Applaus]
en sind glücklich wir sagen den
korrupten Politikern dass Sie unsere
Stimmen respektieren müssen es ist ein
anderes
der für Wandel in seinem Land angetreten
war weiß genau dass alte Eliten
versuchen ihm den Wahlsieg zu nehmen
seine Kandidatur nachträglich für
ungültig zu erklären
muss das ist schon im Gang wir hoffen
dass das überzeugende Ergebnis dieser
Wahl dafür sorgt dass jeder versucht das
weitere Verfahren zu stoppen scheitern
wird
Widersacherin Sandra Torres bekam nur
37% der Stimmen die ehemalige First Lady
gilt als Kandidatin der etablierten
Parteien die tief in Korruption
versteckt sind sie hatten schon vor der
Wahl versucht wegen angeblicher
registrierungsfehler zu disqualifizieren
auch deshalb überwachten Wahlbeobachter
die Abstimmung
.inhaber jammerte gratulierte arrivalo
jetzt zum Wahl sich schon bei der
Stimmabgabe sagte er die Demokratie
müsste respektiert werden
hier wird die Macht am 14 Januar
übergeben egal wer es ist wichtig ist
dass das Volk entscheidet und dass das
rechtlich bestätigt wird
Verliererin Torres will das Ergebnis
prüfen lassen sollte arrevalo der Einzug
in den Präsidenten Palast verwehrt
werden könnte der Jubel umschlagen in
Empörung und Gewalt
in Spanien sorgt ein Kuss für ziemliche
Fassungslosigkeit mitten im Jubel über
die gewonnene Weltmeisterschaft küsste
der Präsident des spanischen
Fußballvereins Verbands eine Spielerin
erst auf die Wangen und dann mit
Nachdruck auf den Mund was hätte ich tun
sollen sagt die 33-Jährige der Mann hat
sich entschuldigt zurückgetreten ist er
nicht die Freude über den Sieg ist
trotzdem riesig Thomas Walde
nach dem Schlusspfiff war vor dem Jubel
in dieser Halle in Madrid
wir haben in ganz Spanien Geschichte
geschrieben das ist für Frauen super
wichtig das bedeutet sehr viel auf
nationaler Ebene wie auch für die Frauen
sie spielen wunderbar auch besser als
die Männer Frauen an die Macht
an eine Szene überschattete den
jubelverbandchef Luis robiales hier
rechts im Bild küsste die Spielerin
Jennifer ermoto auf den Mund darauf
angesprochen sagte er muss so in
sozialen Medien das habe ihr nicht
gefallen
Spaniens Gleichstellungsministerin
Montero kritisierte den Verbandschef es
ist eine Form der sexuellen Gewalt die
wir Frauen täglich erleiden und die
bisher unsichtbar war und die werden
nicht normalisieren dürfen die
Zustimmung steht im Mittelpunkt nur ein
Jahr ist ein Jahr
Spaniens Zeitungen drückten Freude aus
über den Sieg und Empörung über das
Nachspiel der Kuss hat Jenny nicht
gefallen uns auch nicht am Nachmittag
entschuldigte sich rubiales es war
sicherlich ein Fehler das muss ich
zugeben es war in einem ergreifenden
Moment ohne jegliche böse Absicht es ist
nun mal passiert und es war sehr spontan
a so mischt sich in den Jubel das
Eingeständnis dass der Verbandschef dem
Siegtor der Spanierinnen eines
hinzugefügt hat ein Eigentor
noch mehr Weltmeister gab es bei der
Leichtathletik WM
der schnellste Mann der Welt und der
heißt Noahs wieder ein US-Amerikaner der
vierte WM-Sieg über 100 Meter in Serie
für die USA in der Königsklasse der
Sprinter und was für ein mitreißender
Lauf gestern Abend
der 26-Jährige links im Bild erwischte
eine für seine Verhältnisse starken
Staat und kam mit der neuen weltjahres
Bestzeit von 9,83 Sekunden Ziel vor die
Ziele die Hugo aus botana und dem Briten
Sanel Jungs
ja und heute der dritte Wettkampftag
Norbert König in Budapest was erwartet
uns da gleich
da erwartet uns vor allem eine
Trainingspartnerin des schnellsten
Mannes der Welt und die ist angereist
mit dem Titel als schnellste Frau
Europas gerne erinnern wir uns noch mal
an die European Championships in München
als Gina lückenkämper dritte von links
in einer spektakulären Millimeter
Entscheidung zu Gold gerast und gestürzt
ist
10,99 Sekunden hat sie gebraucht und
falls sie nachher wieder diese
Schallmauer durchbrechen sollte um
Halbfinale dann stehen die Chancen nicht
schlecht dass sie nachher um 9:50 Uhr
als erste deutsche seit 26 Jahren in
einem wm-entlauf über 100m startet heute
vor einem Jahr hat sie mit ihren drei
Kolleginnen auch noch Staffel Gold bei
der EM in München gewonnen das ist
vielleicht ein gutes Omen vier
Entscheidungen und reichlich
Qualifikationen haben wir zu bieten bis
gleich also live im ZDF um 19:25 sehen
wir uns wieder Danke Norbert
kurze Rückblick auf die beiden
Bundesliga Sonntagsspiele Union gegen
Mainz klare Sache 4:1 Frankfurt dagegen
nur mit einem knappen 1:0 gegen
Aufsteiger Darmstadt durch das Tor von
Polo myani in der 40 Minute gelungene
Einstand für dinotopmüller als neuer
Eintracht Trainer
und alle Tore alle Höhepunkte des ersten
Spieltags zu sehen bei uns auf heute.de
und in der heute App
U20 Bundestrainer ist er ja schon jetzt
wird Hannes Wolf zu dem neuer
dfb-direktor für Nachwuchstraining und
Entwicklung zwei weitere Top-Positionen
will der Verband zeitnah besetzten
ja unglaubliche 3 Stunden und 49 Minuten
dauerte gestern Abend der Final Krimi
beim Tennisturnier in Cincinnati und
dann hatte Nowak Djokovic Matchball
gegen Carlos al Caras und gewann mit
fünf zu sieben sieben zu sechs sieben zu
sechs ein packendes Duell zwischen den
Weltrangliste der ersten aus Spanien und
dem zweiten aus Serbien
Tennis zum allerfeinsten macht einen
guten Vorgeschmack auf die US Open
nächste Woche ja danke schön morgen
wird's heiß im Süden und warm im Norden
die Details hat gleich aus den Herrli
das heute journal mit Marieta Slomka
heute um 22 Uhr Ihnen einen schönen
Abend noch und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter immer noch sehr
heiß in der Mittelmeerregion und in
Südeuropa hier zum Beispiel Richtung
Spanien Temperaturen von 30 bis 45 Grad
sind drin und auch in Deutschland haben
wir es im Süden zumindest mit der 35
Grad Marke zu tun aber die Hitze wird
eingedellt von Nordwesten kommt kühlere
Luft und dieser Übergang zur mäßigeren
kühleren Luft wird mit Pauken und
Trompeten stattfinden also mit Unwettern
am Freitag wir schauen in die Nacht da
gibt es etwas Regen nach Norden denn
sonst ist es trocken bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 20 Grad im Südwesten
und 12 Grad Richtung oder morgen dann im
Tagesverlauf viel Sonnenschein im Osten
auch mal einige Quellwolken in den
östlichen und südlichen Mittelgebirgen
kann es mal anschauen oder ein Gewitter
geben Temperaturen dazu maximal 35 Grad
im Südwesten und 23 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein ja Hitze Gewitter
gibt es in den nächsten Tagen weiterhin
Mittwoch bis 35 Grad Donnerstag werden
die durchaus ein wenig heftiger und am
Freitag gibt's dann wahrscheinlich
Unwetter ein schöner Abend